he said this whoever acknowledges me  before men he will acknowledge for the  father in heaven whoever disowns me I'll  disown him to the father those words are  written in red so they're important and  that's it that's it that's what we're  going with pretty simple in it thanks  for your time come on let's go do some  acknowledging  careful Sherman it's a booby trap one  wrong step and we're done for the boat  of raw sales straight today take the  wrong boat man will pay all right  Sherman now it's your turn ah the bottom  also straight play hey guys listen I'd  love to do that too but we've barely  gotten back together we don't want to  mess that up okay I am inundated with  offers of Management at the moment One  Direction u2 Cirque de Soleil just some  of the acts I can list wow that's good  this and now I wanna tour manage you  guys it can't be I want to be brave and  I want to be selfless intelligent and  honest and kind well still work out kind  you